okay hello richard hello steve good to
see you
[Music]
so i am nice to see you i'm very happy
to have with me today richard simcott
who and he won't like this term but he's
kind of like the godfather of these
international polyglot gatherings
and in fact he is because he created the
first one and he's a very well-known
polyglot and presence in the sort of
international polyglot community and
today i want to talk about or with
richard about his latest project so
welcome richard well thank you steve
well i don't know who you are and if i'm
the godfather who are you
gonna have to think of a nice nickname
for yourself steve
i'm the old guy sitting on the park
bench
anyway
at least at least are you throwing beer
cans at people who pass by as well or
not
darn right
waiting for someone to come and sit
beside me so i can talk to them in some
language
but
you of course are the creator in my
opinion of the polyglot gathering yeah i
think it was called the polyglot
conference and then there were other
similar events polyglot gathering
landfest in montreal and and everyone
collab collaborates very closely in all
of these things and there was going to
be a polyglot conference with the
collaboration of long fest
in cholula mexico and now with the
covert that's not going to happen and
instead you have embarked on a new idea
indeed and i would ask you to explain it
absolutely well i'm thrilled to be here
and thrilled to be talking to you and to
tell you about what we're doing so
this year obviously with what's going on
around the world with the pandemic our
original plan was to go to tudor like
you said and now we're going to make it
a truly global conference we've been
given this opportunity to really open it
up to the entire world
so
what's going to happen is we're all
going to be using the polyglot
conference.com website as a base
uh people can register there already
there's a forum where people are already
talking to each other ahead of the
conference and we're going to put
information and drip feed it through
that
platform and then what we'll do is we'll
have an entire area where people can
talk to each other they can practice
their languages our
sponsor italki is organizing rooms with
their teachers as well to have kind of
guided conversations and they will take
place all the way through the day no
matter where you are in the world you
will always have the opportunity to meet
up with people so in that sense it will
be truly global
we're also going to start sorry go ahead
can i stop for a second give me once
again the website the url because we're
going to flash it on the screen okay
polyblot conference.com
okay and the dates
the dates are from the 16th to the 25th
of october
okay sorry to interrupt you no you're
very welcome very important information
to share and yet it's going to be you
heard right it's a 10 day period this
year so what we're doing is we're taking
advantage of what we've been given so
instead of just making lemonade out of
lemons we're making really sweet
lemonade that we want to drink
so basically with all of the
presentations they're pre-recorded which
means that we're going to have a netflix
drop style on friday evening we will
drop all of the presentations people can
watch them at their leisure there's no
fear of missing out if people want to
get together and organize
viewing parties they can do that they
can chat around the presentations they
can watch them binge watch them if they
want if they don't feel like talking
then they can just jump in and start
asking questions in the comments section
on the videos themselves
and then they can also
join in with
live aspects of the conference talking
to different sponsors like link for
example
like other sponsors that we've got with
italki teachers around the whole time
and the other sponsors we've got
advertised on the website too you have
chance to to meet mingle meet with other
participants practice your languages get
to know each other take part in some of
the great you talk activities with lang
fest for the competitions you know these
sort of fun activities too there's going
to be a lot going on over the 10 days
but the cool thing is is we do have 10
days we don't have to rush you we don't
have to have everybody waiting up all
night because
this fear of missing out you're going to
fit it around your normal schedule if
your weekend happens to be thursday
friday instead of saturday sunday then
you can take part whenever you're ready
whenever you want and it's also donation
based so
if you can't afford or you don't feel
able to afford a moment to give money
you're still welcome to join us wherever
you are in the world all you need is
your internet connection
something to log into onto the website
and of course
a love of language you don't have to be
a polyglot it's called a polyglot
conference only because it was born out
of that community original community
online you just have to have a love of
language so even if you're interested in
learning your first language you're
going to be made very very welcome
and then the other very important thing
is you need to smile
and even steve's smiling girls these
things
questions a few questions that come to
mind first of all what languages are
these presentations going to be in
that's very so far based on what you
have so far so so far we've got a number
of languages um so we've got
off the top of my head we've got one in
russian i know we've got them in ladino
um in
portuguese
uh obviously in english
quite a lot in english
people often do tend to write them in
english we encourage other languages but
we do get a lot of english
um
there's gonna be
one in asl there are a couple of
multilingual ones already
um which have
various languages included like finnish
um
swedish
italian
um i think
spanish as well we've got we're gonna
have a number of others already just
waiting on them to come in
okay now question
uh since it's uh pre-recorded and you
mentioned netflix are there subtitles
are there translated subtitles
so what we're trying to do is make sure
that the subtitles are ready for when
the conference starts so some of the
videos have already got subtitles
attached to them and some of them are
translated into different languages we
have one that's got english and persian
subtitles for example because it's about
iran and about the persian language so
um we have got some of them already
we're working with a volunteer team now
to create
subtitles where we don't have them for
all of them and it's not just for the
language aspect but also for the
accessibility for people with
say hearing issues where they can't hear
what's being said they can at least
follow by reading them
and uh another thing is the original
intention was that the polyglot
conference would take place in cholula
mexico
is there any particular mexican cholula
theme to this conference or is it purely
global
so this conference itself is global and
of course we are looking towards mexico
as well so one of the themes that we
we asked people to submit presentations
under was the road to cholula so we're
going to have things about noaa about
life in mexico um about mexico itself
and so we will have the elements of that
uh included i know that anya and her
team at solar languages
who've partnered with us for this year
as well as next year
they've been very busy actually creating
materials creating videos presentations
that are going to be of interest for
anybody with a fascination for mexico
and uh still joining us in cholula
hopefully next year
right
can you can you give us an idea because
you mentioned
is this the most widely spoken uh
indigenous language in mexico and how
widely spoken is it compared to quechua
compared to
guarani in paraguay in other words how
big a language is in the hotel
um
so it's a very difficult question to
answer um
i i'm not sure how it compares to the
other ones i wouldn't have those facts
in my head i'd need to google that
or at least to ask somebody with with
with better information than i've got
um
but it is the local language of terula
so that's the local indigenous language
of toronto which is why nawaz is always
mentioned so
when we talk about the conference in
cholula now the noah language when you
talk about
language is actually many different
know-how languages there are and it and
it spans over central america so it's
not just
one no after language in in mexico
it's the same thing with the mayan
language they're actually the mind
languages so
they can sometimes be as diverse as
indo-european languages can be diverse
so it could be
you know as different as french and
italian where they're not really going
to be able to have a conversation with
each other if they meet in the street
right
now another question that i have this
global conference looks like a it's like
so much that's happening around covid
how much of this stuff is going to
change how we live how we work how we
behave how we learn
so do you think there are elements of
what you're doing for this global
polyglot conference that will
carry forward into future
polyglot conferences
um well yes is the short answer to that
um yes i do i think that
it would be
foolish to to think that we're going to
go back to just the way it was before i
think that this has been a game changer
for many many reasons and i think
the the sort of throwing the baby out
with the bath water and not
not retaining what's what's good about
what's happened would be foolish i think
that there are a number of lessons
to learn as a an events organizer to how
we can actually add value to the
conferences in the future so i would
definitely like to see this global
element
continue uh throughout of course i think
there's there's always something to be
said about getting together in person
breaking bread going out exploring a
city exploring a country together as a
group and it would be
absolutely awful to think that we
weren't going to do that again so
i would definitely not want to go down
that road and just say we're going to do
it all online from now on but at the
same time
there's an inclusiveness about doing it
globally and
also taking this 10-day period
is really quite exciting because we're
not restricted by times we're not
restricted by space and by renting
certain areas to say okay you have to
speak this amount of time
at this time on this day and that's it
if it doesn't happen then if that's it's
gone
whereas right now with this we can say
if your presentation presentation's 10
minutes long it's 10 minutes long
doesn't matter it's not like you have to
sort of occupy the stage and change
things over mics and things it's all
done until ready so we've got a lot of
advantages from this that i think would
be foolish to throw out and not retain
one last question
you mentioned the word inclusiveness and
i've always felt that at our polyglot
gatherings conferences long fest
everyone i meet there
is able to put five six eight nine ten
badges on their chest
indicating the languages they speak
and i've always felt that we are
kind of lim we always limit ourselves to
those people who have already taken the
plunge into
polyglotism and enjoy learning lots of
languages and that there's a whole bunch
of people on the sidelines
that we should be
you know getting into the swimming pool
with us
what
are you doing to get people who maybe
don't even speak one other language or
you know speak one poorly and like what
are we doing to broaden the base beyond
you know hardcore polyglots okay so um i
mean the name the name is the name of
the conference it's the name of the
event right polyglot conference
but we do have a tagline and it says for
everyone who loves language so we don't
even say languages we say f for everyone
who loves language and it's true i mean
you can join the conference even if you
just speak english or you just speak
french or you just speak another
language okay you might not understand
all of the all of the content but
there's always something in there for
you because we have talks from
many many areas so
every year we have themes at the
conference so we've attracted people in
the past say in reykjavik in iceland one
of the themes was
autism and multilingualism so how people
with autism are affected when they have
more than one language in the home
environment or outside
and people came in and showed their
research or their research plans for
phds to discuss that from academia
and we also had people
like daniel tammet come over to talk
about his experience learning icelandic
as somebody with asperger's syndrome now
we attracted people who came to the
conference
who were interested in the autism side
of things
and maybe have been interested a little
bit in languages
and they saw that actually it's really
uh
applicable to them and the people that
were at the event were not these elitist
people who were you know saying oh you
don't speak enough languages or anything
like that and every year because we
change this theme and because we add on
in in slovenia we had a language
learning day
just for people who were learning the
first second or third whatever language
and we invited anyone and everyone to
come so we had a full day for those
people to come and to join in
and just to sort of show them how
approachable we are and you know as well
as i do we're a pretty friendly bunch
and i think oh the friendliness and the
the people are just accepted regardless
of whatever there is not a more
supportive group than the polyglot group
but i guess i guess what i feel you know
for people who love language there's a
lot of people who think they might love
language but they have this recollection
of trying to learn languages at school
and they sort of say well i can't do it
you know i'd love to speak spanish but
you know it's a lot of work or i can't
do it or i was bad at it in school and
and i just think if we can get people
into the sort of environment that you
just described this environment of a
bunch of friendly supportive people that
that might encourage more people to
learn languages so hopefully we will
encourage some of those people to join
us virtually and realize and sort of uh
get the fever so to speak yeah and i
hope that you know things like this
talking about this kind of topic is
really important so the more we talk
about and then we'll repeat the mantra
of everybody's welcome and it doesn't
matter whether you're your first or your
31st language you're you're welcome at
the polyglot conference and i think that
everybody's going to find friends
and i've met people who have come for
the the very first time and they said
they were they were sort of a bit
anxious about coming you know about the
event and they were quite open about
that and then they said actually you
know what i don't know why i was so
anxious and i don't know why i waited
and i don't know why i missed that year
and i waited to this year to come
because everyone's so nice and they make
friends for life they end up going on
holidays together they end up talking
together online and meeting with each
other outside the conference and every
year i hear the same kinds of stories
and it encourages me that we are opening
up we are opening out and reaching out
and you know
i always give this example actually from
my own life
one of the most inspiring people that i
met in in terms of languages was a
monolingual english speaker who was just
so well read and had a wealth of
knowledge and a depth of knowledge of
the english language that that person
actually inspired me
in my own language learning
as much if not more than many other
multilinguals i've met
well we're going to leave a link in the
description box
uh we certainly don't look down our
noses at people who only speak one
language
uh but we do enjoy the company of our
enthusiastic and friendly polyglots and
so i'm looking forward to the conference
i'm looking forward looking forward to
connecting with you and anya and the
others
uh virtually this year and hopefully the
following year in cholula
yes me too
thank you very much richard we'll be in
touch
thank you very much thanks for having me
take care
[Music]